nosotros estamos en el oeste de Ucrania
esa esta ciudad que hace casi un año
llegó esa avalancha de personas que
huían después del inicio de la invasión
de Gran escala de Rusia era el pasado 24
de febrero de 2022 ahora bien lo pueden
ver en esta ciudad se puede observar
cierta normalidad Hay personas que a
estas horas están caminando están
paseando todavía se ven Iglesias tapadas
estatuas que siguen siendo protegidas
por la eventualidad que aquí se
produzcan ataques pero esta instantanea
es muy distinta a la del este de Ucrania
a la de especialmente de bahamut donde
en estas horas están viviendo las
batallas más cruentas y donde los
soldados ucranianos también con el
riesgo de quedar atrapados la guerra en
este país continúa el presidente
ucraniano blodomiselessky ha dicho que
en las últimas horas unas 10 provincias
de este país han sido atacadas Y
lamentablemente también ha habido
víctimas mortales